[Applause]
thank you
ouch
Joy Behar just fell out of her seat live
on air it was like my big moment it all
went down
literally when the 79 year old daytime
TV host made her entrance on Thursday's
episode of The View
[Applause]
come on just stop just stand
let me tell you
these chairs move you touch it and you
and you're on the ground yeah she like
really ate it
but I love how her co-hosts were there
in like a nanosecond to help her get off
the ground I needed warm-up you know you
just sort of thrown into it it's
happened to all of us at 25 years that
has never happened
[Applause]
and don't worry guys Joy says she's
totally fine I went flying you yeah you
did they're also High we can't even say
you know you can't have another glass of
wine it takes a glass of wine to get in
the chair yeah you're all right you're
fine yeah
I just missed the step as usual okay all
right well that's our show today thank
you so much
of course the ladies of the view have
been in the headlines a lot lately
people like a train wreck just last week
Sherry Shepard who was a co-host on the
show from 2007 to 2014 through some not
so subtle shade at another former view
panelist during a stop by Watch What
Happens live with Andy Cohen which view
guest was the biggest disappointment
once you met them in person oh
I don't know I can't McCain weight
yeah McCain weight that translates to
Megan McCain who co-hosted the daytime
talk show years after Sherry's departure
from 2017 to 2021. I think that's why
people like the show is they know it's
not scripted and they know it's not
we're not being phony and I'm not trying
to placate to an audience Sherry later
poked fun at her Shady comment tweeting
about drinking on the show and getting
in trouble quote all I can say is don't
drink and then answer questions no it
was all good then there's Whoopi
Goldberg who recently returned to her
chair on the panel following a two-week
suspension after she said this on
February 1st let's be truthful about it
because the Holocaust isn't about race
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about later that night
will be addressed her controversial
comments on The Late Show it upset a lot
of people which was never ever ever my
intention I feel being black when we
talk about race it's a very different
thing to me I think of race as being
something that I can see so I see you
and I know what race you are and
the discussion was about how I felt
about that I felt that that it was
really more about man's inhumanity to
man and how horrible people can be to
people will be also issued an apology on
Twitter saying in part that she was
sorry for the hurt that she caused we
try to do the best we can but the
following day Kim Godwin president of
ABC News released a statement to ET that
the egot winner would be suspended for
two weeks giving her time to reflect and
learn about the impact of her comments
and when Whoopi returned she opened up
about her time off camera I listened to
everything everybody had to say and I
was very grateful and I hope it keeps
all the important conversations
happening because we're going to keep
having tough conversations and in part
because this is what we've been hired to
do and all that Echoes what will be told
E.T back in September we're doing what
we're supposed to be doing this is our
this is our game again this is you know
our gift from the world because not
everybody gets to have an opinion not
everybody gets to say this is what I
think and here's why and let's talk
about this this is a really great job
it's a really great job and I'm going to
speak for us but I think we're luckiest
[Music]